the biggest Jewish community outside
Israel lives in New York City
nearly half of Orthodox Jews here are
hardened or ultra-orthodox many of the
men devote themselves to studying the
Torah most of the women start having
children early and look after the
household but traditional gender roles
in this community are beginning to
change parole in Dalia have founded the
first ultra-orthodox women's rock band
but can they make it as rock musicians
without being shut out of the community
many of New York City's ultra-orthodox
Jews about 300,000 live in a world of
their own in Brooklyn Pearl grew up in
this world her skirt reaches below her
knees but it's a bit tight putting it at
the edge of respectability a trained
makeup artist she virtually lives at the
edge of rules laws and customs pearls
visiting her friend Feige a closer
inspection reveals that both are wearing
wigs
I'm not married I a lot of girls who are
divorced who don't cover their hair or
you know to take their hair covering are
after their divorce and I decided not to
because I couldn't I don't know I felt
naked it'll soon be Shabbat pearl makes
Feige up very thoroughly it has to last
for two days they can't put any makeup
on during Shabbat I makeup will stay
probably most of the day those lipstick
Amman users also last like a day or two
yeah face stuff is usually what comes
off cuz I've even stood I feel like it
stays on me it just fades right when no
men are around the women speak openly
about the religious rules that even
define intimacy with their husbands
there are certain times and when a woman
gets her period she's not allowed to
touch her husband he's not allowed to
touch her until she goes to the mikveh
because the it's not that she's
considered impure but the I guess the
the period you know the blood I don't
know if you wanna go to the cardio
ritual it's a good issue out there is
entered impure because the word up here
what a period is is the the I guess
quote-unquote death of a like what could
i potentially do yes not touching yeah
however it gets easy
pearl buys flowers for Shabbat like
other women in the community she's
supposed to avoid drawing attention to
herself in public but pearl is doing the
exact opposite she's got a camera team
on her as a passerby points out there's
no of everywhere yes it's not a person
I've spoken to many rub on him in this
community about this specifically
because they're filming me because of I
make music for women I make I'm a singer
for women and I've been told by every
rub I spoke to hear that for sure it's
not a question but we didn't tell them
on the street did you of course I did
yes absolutely absolutely
I don't think it's appropriate choice
okay it's not it's not doesn't go
putting salt off huh what is that what
would be the halacha though mayorship
I'm not getting into this secular
matters have no place here at the
offices of the online news service
Jewish political updates we meet Jack of
corn blue he's agreed to speak to us not
something to be taken for granted
he says every family here has six or
seven children he only has four he says
they get married at 1920 at the latest
so women have little time for higher
education the woman is more at home
cooking taking care of the kids the
education of the kids putting the kids
onto the buses in the morning going to
school one of the main are bringing up
the children is not to be out there in
the world you know the world is quite
dangerous
and what looks so harmless here is in
reality a minor revolution pearl and her
friend alia have started the first
Hasidic woman's rock band usually only
Orthodox men sing in public women aren't
supposed to sing for men they're also
not supposed to stand on stage so it's a
kind of revolution because they're here
to make an album and sing in public and
rock music at that not everyone in their
community thinks that's kosher
you
dancing morning army
ha
some people are afraid of it too like Oh
rock music that's very secular thing you
know it's like rock and roll is is
associated with a whole scene which is
not necessarily you know uh associated
with the Hasidic community yeah not
quite the same vibration they call
themselves bulletproof stockings there's
a religious element to their lyrics and
their music is bold
sometimes brash it's a far cry from the
quiet and submissive role many associate
with Hasidic women us a quick morning
prayer Dahlia washes her youngest son's
hands after sleep Oh
religious rules like these set the
rhythm of dahlias life the drummer is
the mother of four little boys her
husband died four years ago since then
Dahlia has raised the kids on her own
other women from the community help out
and they admire her sense of
Independence oh yeah yes not Kay busy
okay that means your best each child
attends a different Jewish school the
school buses arrive at the door every
few minutes
thank you
it's a different take on feminism like
we're not here to do anything but like
it's not it's not we're not doing
anything against we're just doing like
we're like jumping over that hurdle we
don't have to fight against and break
down like walls in the sense of like you
know we need to liberate it's a
close-knit community but this being
Brooklyn you can get anything
one local store specializes in winks or
shackles as they're called in Yiddish
they're an accessory that pearl has
always been interested in human hair
wigs are expensive pearl trans out a new
hair color there's no style to it yet
it's not cut turning from her natural
light brown to a darker hue yeah this
one I actually got much cheaper I got
this one for 600 because it's like not
as high-quality the hair but I feel like
if you some shape tools if they're
really not great quality they're not
gonna last but if you know how to take
care of it and wash it and be delicate
with it you can make it look nice even
though like people think this is a
several thousand dollar wig six hundred
dollars after taxes so that's not bad
considering I mean still a lot you're
like has still sounds like a lot of
money well from the end watch it well
you wash it whatever you need to like if
it gets really dirty but you can't wash
it too often because the hair comes out
every time you wash it and every time
you play with it and it doesn't grow
back so you know anytime you shower some
hair comes out but every time you wash
the shades old hair comes out and it
doesn't grow back Dahlia is showing
female solidarity in a special way at
the moment she's looking after a woman
who's just given birth shopping for her
and bringing her some breakfast the
community takes care of its mothers of
newborns I usually make dinners for
mothers but her mother's taking care of
the dinner this is just I get her
breakfast if you want to help human
solidarity Oh what is that
that's so impressed
oh it's just community you know whenever
somebody has a baby the community gets
together and makes food for the family
for like at least a week risky recently
had her fifth child
the others are aged six five three and
one the latest addition is a girl called
Ella Chinna
it's very common that friends have
dinners and lunch and breakfast come
that's their a good good friends do you
know it's fun it's not good friend yeah
but they have found oh my god they get
this like a whole network you know as
soon as the baby's born like you know
the message goes out and whoever can
make dinner or lunch whatever I don't
know
yeah really totally it's gig night at an
Orthodox community center in Manhattan
around 40 women have come along men are
not permitted inside at least I am NOT
going to cheat I am going to stand and
work the door the late coming and then I
will act as security as a Orthodox
Jewish woman you're constantly trying to
be humble and you're trying to be modest
and that's kind of a way in which you
live life and so when you're in
situations where that might be
challenged you have to try to think oh
no what do I do in this situation in
this situation like this what's nice
it's all women so
can feel that a sense of freedom what
might look like a poorly attended night
school event is in fact something of a
sensation the audience are initially
reserved for a few of the women dancing
in public is a totally foreign concept
but eventually some get up and start
moving and shakin a rather remarkable
ladies night